Hello everyone. Good afternoon.
I'm back with a lecture on groups or
more precisely
group convolutions on homogeneous
spaces. So that's a bunch of jargon
right there,
but we'll see exactly what this what
this means.
So in the in the previous lecture
you heard about convolution on grids
and that is of course the the most most
common situation in deep learning
when people use convolutional networks
for images or 3D volumes. Usually
they're doing some kind of convolution.
But what we'll look at in this lecture
is how to generalize this from
convolutions that are equivariant to
translation
to convolutions that can deal with more
general groups of transformations
including
mainly rotations, rotations of planar
images, 3D volumes,
spherical signals
and in fact a far more general class of
groups and and spaces on which they act
called so
the so called the homogeneous spaces.
So after looking at some examples,
I'll
give you a high-level idea of the of the
general theory that's that's been
developed for these kind of
convolutional networks.
And at the end of the lecture, I'll talk
about an even further generalization to
so called induced representations and
steerable CNNs
which um
geometrically you can think of as
convolutional networks that have as
input output and also as internal
feature spaces
spaces of fields on a on a space. Things
like vector fields, tensor fields and so
on. And
what I'll come back to multiple times in
this lecture is the convolution is all
you need theorem
which
says basically that
when you have a feature space that's a
space of signals or space of fields on a
homogeneous space, then the most general
kind of equivariant linear map is indeed
a convolution of a generalized kind.
Okay, so let's get started and we'll
start with a very simple example and
also
the first one that that was published
about in the
in the deep learning literature.
So the idea here is let me get out my
pointer.
Right, so the idea is we have an image
and just like in the in the in the case
of
grids and translational convolutions
we can take a filter
say this this little patch
containing an eye like pattern
and we can convolve it translationally
over our image. So we're going to
translate the filter and at each
position compute some kind of inner
product, some kind of match between the
filter
and our image and we'll register a
response and you know in this case you
see well this eye detector filter it it
fires
of course in the position of the of the
eyes.
And that's a that's a translational
convolution. We can do it with any
number of filters, so we can have an eye
filter and a mouth filter which fires
here in the green spot. We can have any
number of them.
Just as in a in a standard CNN.
But now what we want to do is we want to
increase the weight sharing. We don't
just want to use the same filter at
every position.
We also want to use the same filter in
different orientations. So we want to
apply a rotation.
I'm getting
So
that's indicated in this figure here at
the top. We rotate the filter in this
very simple case. We'll just rotate by
90°.
And we get a
eye detector for vertically oriented
eyes. And when we convolve it of course
at least in this sort of simplified
cartoon picture of what could happen,
it doesn't fire at all because the eyes
here are in the horizontal orientation.
It's an upright face. So this feature
map doesn't give us a big response and
similarly when we rotate by 180 or 270°,
we we don't get any big responses as we
did in the upright orientation.
But of course you can see that when we
rotate the the input image, then those
smarts might start to to fire.
So what we've achieved here first of all
is is increased weight sharing. So
whereas in a in a standard translational
CNN,
you might need to learn the same filter
in different orientations. Here this is
automatically
this is built in.
And in cases where the data has
rotational symmetry, that's that's a
very useful thing as has been shown many
times in empirical results.
For example, in medical imaging where
you know medical tissues might appear in
any any kind of orientation.
Now
what we've been emphasizing in this
course is of course this notion of
equivariance. So let's see if this
operation that we've defined is indeed
equivariant. So we'll take our our image
and we apply a transformation, 90°
rotation. Again, this is just a very
simple example.
We apply an element from our group, the
90° rotation and then we apply the same
operation. So again we're going going to
take our two filters. In general could
be more, but here we have two filters.
Apply them translationally, rotate them,
apply again translationally, etc.
And we generate two times four feature
maps.
Now what you can
can see is that when we apply the
upright
eye detector, it's not going to fire
because now the eyes are in the uh
the sideways orientation.
However, the rotated filter is now going
to pick up on that. So
we see now firing in this orientation
channel as we call it.
So when we look at what happened as we
go from the top right, that's the
feature response to the original image
to the bottom right, that's the feature
response for the rotated image
we see that we can describe this
transformation, this downward arrow here
as two
in two steps.
Basically here we have these these
responses on a horizontal line and here
we have it on a vertical line. So the
first thing that happens is that the
all the channels, they will undergo a
rotation. In this case 90° rotation.
But another thing happened, right? Here
we had firing in the theta equals zero
orientation channel.
And here we have it
in the theta equals pi over two or 90°
rotated channel.
So in addition to the spatial rotation
there's a cyclic shift along these four
orientation channels. So so what was
originally theta zero goes to pi over
two, what was in pi over two goes to pi,
what was in pi goes to
3 pi over two and what was in 3 pi over
two goes to zero.
You can you can try to visualize this
mentally or or do some calculations on a
piece of paper to convince yourself that
this is always true.
And now this is a very general pattern
that we'll come back to again and again
in this this lecture that the
the types of group actions which we find
in the feature space
are first of all different from what we
find in the input space. In the input
space we just take the RGB channels and
each of them is rotated independently
and there's no interaction among the
channels. What happens in the feature
space is that the channels are rotated,
there's also this cyclic shift.
And so uh
that's that's quite interesting and it
also helps to motivate the geometric
deep learning blueprints that we've
talked about and that is is the sort of
the backbone of the
the book, the proto book that we we have
on archive on geometric deep learning.
Different group action for each feature
space. And here you see how that sort of
emerges
quite naturally from from a simple idea
of rotating filters. Same group,
rotations and discrete translations, but
it acts in a different way in the
different feature spaces.
So we've verified that this operation is
equivariant, but we've only defined it
for the first layer.
So now
we can we can think about how to create
deeper networks with this basic idea. So
what you see on this figure is
essentially the same thing as on the
previous slide, but visualized slightly
differently. So here we have again our
input image. We can also have a rotated
version of that input image. We have a
filter here which we convolve with the
image to produce one feature map and
then we rotate it, produce another one,
another one and another one. And of
course we can do the same for the
rotated image and then again you see
that the way the two stacks of feature
maps are related on the top and bottom
is that the channels are each channel is
rotated and the channels are cyclically
shifted. Now,
um
what we're going to do for the second
layer and higher layers is to apply the
same general idea, namely we're going to
take a filter and rotate it four times
and then convolve it.
But now rotating has a different meaning
because the feature space transforms in
a different way. It has a different uh
group representation associated with it.
So, in the second layer, first of all, a
filter indicated here uh in the center
uh has four channels.
Uh in any kind of convolutional network,
a filter will have as many channels as
the input feature maps that you convolve
with. In in this case, we have four
orientation channels, so our filter has
also four orientation channels.
Um so, we can convolve such a filter
translationally with this stack of four
feature maps to produce one output
feature map.
But then uh according to the same uh
philosophy as we we used in the first
layer, we're going to rotate this uh
filter and rotation means rotating each
channel and cyclically shifting them.
And what you can see is that if you do
this, you get four filters, so four
output feature maps. And again, you can
see that the whole construction is
equivariant. So, if you rotate the uh
input feature map, you apply the first
layer group convolution
and then the second layer group
convolution using this procedure I just
described, you get four output channels
which are related to the four output
channels produced from the unrotated
image uh in the same way, namely
rotating the channels and cyclically
shifting them.
And finally, what you can then do is you
can do for example, this is just an
example, you can do many things, but you
can you can iterate this a number of
times, have many layers of convolutions,
and then at the end of the network, you
could do some kind of pooling. So, what
you can do is you can in the simplest
case, you would just sum over the four
orientation channels to produce one
number or an average or maybe a you take
a maximum, uh whatever you prefer.
And as a result, you get one channel as
output.
Uh and uh
you can you can uh you can see that when
you do this, the
output will again be equivariant, but it
will transform in exactly the same way
as the input. So, no more there's no
more uh cycling between channels,
there's just if you rotate the input
image and uh compute the uh the output
of the whole network after pooling,
you get uh just the same thing as you
get for the original image, except it's
rotated.
And you can see that that must be the
case because
uh
cyclically shifting along the channels
will just permute the four values uh
that you're summing, and of course, the
sum adding a bunch of numbers doesn't
depend on
uh the order of those numbers.
Okay, so
how can we understand this uh from the
perspective of our uh general uh
geometric deep learning blueprint?
So, in the input, we have a signal on
some uh on on our domain omega, which in
this case is Z2. That's the uh the grid
uh
extended infinitely
uh of uh consisting of pairs of
integers.
Uh of course, in practice, it's a finite
uh grid, but we sort of imagine that it
extends infinitely far with uh padded
with infinite amounts of zeros,
uh so mathematically, it all works out.
Um right, so that's our that's our base
space omega. And
uh as we'll discuss in more detail
later, the way that these uh feature
maps transform is
uh uh
it's called uh that it it transform as a
scalar signal. So, we have here one
channel
uh that's a scalar at each position. And
if we rotate this uh this channel, uh we
don't have any action on the channels,
it's just uh a rotation as you're used
to.
And then for the first layer and also
higher layers,
the way we can think about this is that
our domain omega now becomes the group.
In this case, the group is is called P4.
That's the group of integer
translations, discrete translations, and
rotations by multiples of 90°.
Uh so, basically, if you look at these
four channels, every pixel in any one of
these channels, you can index it by
saying, well, which channel is it? So,
meaning which uh of the four rotations
uh does it correspond to? And then what
is the spatial position? That is to say,
what is the translation?
And so, indexing by rotation and
translation, that's basically indexing
into this group P4.
And so, in a in a very general uh case,
the feature map after the first layer of
group convolution will be a function on
a group. Uh so, omega becomes equal to
our group.
And then a uh signal on the group uh
uh transform according to what is called
a regular representation. And we'll look
into more detail mathematically what
what that means, but this is just to to
introduce the nomenclature.
Uh and after pooling, of course, our
domain again becomes uh the plane or the
grid Z2, and we have a scalar signal
just like in the input space.
All right, so let's try to understand uh
mathematically how group convolution
works.
Uh and let's do that by making an
analogy to uh you know, the usual
translational convolution.
So, in translational convolution,
the idea is of course that
we have a signal, an image, say,
and we have a filter, and we're going to
translate the filter and compute an
inner product, and then we'll store the
result of this inner product in a cell
of the output feature map that's
associated uh with the translation that
we applied. If we applied if we
translate by five pixels uh along the
x-axis and 10 pixels along the y-axis,
compute the dot product, then we'll take
that cell 5,10 uh and store the output
of the of the inner product there.
In the group convolution case, the idea
is very similar, but we replace the word
translation by transformation.
Uh to that is to say, we apply a not
just a translation, but an arbitrary
element from our group. So, we have our
a signal, our filter, uh and then for
each
transformation in our group, we apply
that transformation to our filter, we
translate and rotate it for example,
compute inner product, and store the
result of the inner product in the cell
of the output feature map associated now
with the transformation
that we applied. And so, that's how you
see that the result should indeed be a
function uh on your group of
transformations that you're considering.
All right, so mathematically, we're
going to unpack this. And the first
concept to unpack is of course this
concept of translation or transformation
applied to our signal or to a filter.
Uh so, we have here uh you know, just to
remind you of the notation, we have a
signal x uh on our domain omega. U is an
element of omega, so we can index our
signal x at the point u.
Then we have a translation v, and
you know, this translation acts on the
signal via the representation rho. And
uh if you recall from the from the third
lecture, the way that works is that
uh the
v-translated
sig uh a version of the signal x indexed
at u is equal to x, the original signal,
indexed at u minus v.
Uh and uh there's a very uh you know,
completely analogous uh uh equation for
a general group.
So, the only thing that changes is that
now g is a is an element of our group,
and when we apply it to our signal and
then index the signal at u, uh that's
going to uh be uh given by uh uh uh the
original signal indexed at g inverse u.
This is just a mathematical way to say,
you know, shift and rotate or whatever
the group may be, your signal.
Then we have the concept of inner
product that we have in our definition
of convolution. So, in the in the
classical case of a discrete grid with
some number of channels c, the inner
product between a signal x and another
signal, let's say a filter y, is given
by summing over all spatial locations
and summing also over all channels
uh the product of
one signal at this position and in this
channel times the other signal at this
position in this channel.
And again, this is was already covered
in lecture three, three, but uh in in
general,
uh when we have a signal on some domain
omega,
uh we can define an inner product for
such signals by uh uh you know,
integrating over the domain. In the case
of a discrete domain omega, that would
be a sum.
Uh in general, it will be a an an
integral with a certain
uh invariant measure.
And then uh at each point, we take the
inner product of the feature vectors
along the channel dimension
uh for X and Y at the that position and
we we we uh integrate the whole thing.
And uh this this gives you a valid inner
product
uh that uh we use to
do pattern matching.
And then convolution
uh and group convolution is defined as
followed.
I should say that uh in the deep
learning literature everybody calls this
convolution even though in some other
fields uh it's more common to uh call
this a cross-correlation,
but we we will not be uh uh uh worrying
about the difference here.
So, the idea is the signal convolved
with a filter psi evaluated at V. So, V
is a translation, so we're evaluating
the output at a certain translation or
position in the plane
is the
uh inner product of the signal and a
transformed filter, the translated
filter, which if we expand the
definition of the inner product is a sum
over positions and channels of the
signal and the translated filter.
And for group convolution we have
something completely analogous.
Um we uh we have our signal convolved
with a filter evaluated now not at a
translation not at a uh
planar position,
but at the
uh group element G.
That's the inner product between X and
our filter
transformed by G, which again we can
expand the definition of the inner
product and the transformation of the
filter and we get this this equation
here.
Uh and in both cases using completely
analogous uh derivation you can show
that this mathematical operation here is
equivariant, meaning that if you apply a
transformation G to your input signal
uh then you get also a that that's
equivalent to just doing the convolution
with the original signal and then
transforming the output.
Now,
one very nice thing to note here
uh is that
uh this the all this whole uh setup
works uh no matter what your space omega
is and in particular it also works when
omega is the group itself as we saw
happens after the the first layer. So,
you could have uh
X being a signal on the group, so now U
is a group element and then the
transformation of a signal on the group
is still given by this equation uh where
we now have G inverse U, that's now the
composition operation in the group and
then the whole uh the rest of the uh the
setup still still works. It's still
equivariant. And indeed um that uh is a
mathematical way of saying what or let's
say it the this this setup specializes
to the case I just explained for the
roto-translation group in a more
intuitive way.
All right, so we've we studied uh
the group convolution
um and I mentioned already that the the
way that the feature maps uh in a group
convolutional net transform is called
the regular representation. So, let's
look a little bit more in more a little
bit more detail uh what that means.
Um so,
uh recall that uh signals are functions
X from omega or domain to C, some vector
space
and they transform according to this
equation. We've just seen it on the
previous slide.
Um
And what I was also already mentioning
is that
in the case where omega is the group
itself as we have in the second and
higher layers of a uh group equivariant
net
um you can you can take this G inverse U
to mean the left action of G on itself.
So, if you have instead of U you have an
element H and you want to make you want
to apply the transformation G to it, you
just use the composition operation of
the group. And you can verify that this
also satisfies the axioms of a of a of a
group action.
Uh
so, this is a valid group action and it
fits into the framework. It's just a
special case where omega happens to be
equal to the group G.
Um and then this way that the signal
transforms is called is known as the
regular representation.
So, we have our X that's a feature map.
Now, it's feature map on the group G.
For example, as we saw before, for every
translation and rotation we have a
certain uh value uh certain feature
response.
Uh and the way that we can transform
such a thing using a group element G,
say again a rotation and translation, is
to just index the original feature map
at G inverse X.
Uh so, let's look at uh how that general
definition specializes to the case that
we've been been studying of uh discrete
rotations and translations.
So, to make it less abstract uh to do to
actually be able to do
concrete computations we're going to
encode our group elements G as matrices
and because the group that we're dealing
with here is the group of discrete
translations and rotations uh the
matrices are indexed by a rotation R
either 0 1 2 or 3 corresponding to 0
degrees, 90 degrees 180 or 270 degrees
and a translation in in Z in the grid
Z2.
And the way we construct the matrix is
like this. We have here in the uh
top left a rotation matrix that rotates
by R times pi over 2.
Uh we can also write that here as a 2 by
2 rotation matrix capital R of lower
case R.
Uh and then we have here our translation
in the X and Y direction, which we also
can encode here as a two-dimensional
vector in this block matrix.
And you can verify that uh
when you compose matrices like this,
that's the correct way to compose
rotations and and translations.
You might have seen this in a in a
computer vision class uh for example.
Uh and you can also see that if you
apply this to a uh two-dimensional
vector with an added one uh as a third
component uh this gives the correct way
to transform uh a two-dimensional point
in the plane.
Now, uh
in the definition of the regular
representation we have two uh kinds of
operations that play a role. The first
is the group operation. Well, in that
case for this encoding of the group
elements it's just matrix multiplication
and you can uh you know, do the do the
the the the linear algebra here and work
with some uh rules for uh the the sine
and cosine and you can verify that when
you compose these matrices you get this
matrix. So, the the rotation angles they
add up modulo uh four because they get
wrapped in the in the sinusoids.
Uh and the way the rotations and
translations compose is then that the
rotation of the first uh group element
acts on the translation of the second
one and then you add the translation of
the the first one. It's just a matter of
linear algebra. You can you can verify
this and also verify that indeed if you
apply this roto-translation and this
roto-translation to a point, that's the
same as applying this combined
roto-translation.
And similarly, you can do an exercise to
verify that the inverse of this matrix
is given by this matrix, which is again
an element of this of this group.
Then uh we look at the definition of the
the regular representation. Now, we have
our signal. Signal uh is is a function
on the group. In this case that means
it's indexed by a rotation 0 to 3
uh and a translation in the grid. And
let's say we apply just a pure rotation
to it with no translation just to keep
things simple.
Then you can use these two definitions
or these two results here
for what it means to compose and invert
uh group elements to derive that uh uh
this transformed signal is is is given
by the original signal indexed
at R minus R prime mod 4. So, that's how
your cyclic shifting along the channels
comes in.
Uh and uh how the spatial dimension is
affected by this rotation.
So, that's how, you know, the thing we
saw on the the very first slide uh
how that uh
uh emerges as a special case of a
regular representation.
Now, this is of course a more
complicated way to think about it, but
uh
the nice thing is that this regular
representation is a very general concept
that applies to many uh situations uh
and that indeed there's a large
mathematical literature uh that proves
all sorts of results about these these
things. So, it's nice to see that the
that the the thing we already understood
can also be understood in this more
general framework.
Um and indeed you can generalize it to
all sorts of other groups. So, here's a
one example, uh the group of discrete
rotations in 3D. So, let's say you have
a three-dimensional voxel grid. Uh maybe
you have some MRI brain scans and you
want to do some kind of learning on it
to segment different brain regions or
classify certain disease states or uh uh
what whatever it may be.
Um then you can use say a 3 by 3 by 3
filter
in a convolution layer and we can apply
the same idea. We can rotate this this
filter using discrete rotations just to
keep it simple.
Uh, but actually you see already in 3D
the there are many many ways to rotate
your filter.
Uh, in fact 24 ways if I recall
correctly.
And um,
that is in in a way it's because it
gives us a lot of weight sharing and so
a lot of statistical efficiency. We're
going to need fewer examples to learn
from.
Um,
of course it also has a computational
cost. That's something we'll talk about
in a minute. Uh, but the other
interesting thing I wanted to mention
here is that
whereas in a simple case of
two-dimensional
discrete rotations, you get simple
cyclic shift along the channels.
What's indicated diagram is that these
group elements in 3D are related in a
very intricate pattern and so the the
the instead of a cyclic shift, you get a
fairly complicated permutation for each
rotation that you might apply.
So the channels undergo this permutation
that's indicated by the arrows here.
Okay, so um,
we already sort of convinced ourselves
that just intuitively that the group
convolution uh, for the special case of
discrete rotations and translation that
that should be equivariant.
Uh, but let's let's verify it
mathematically or see how we can prove
that in the general case.
So we have our input
that's going to be a signal on the space
omega one. Could be for example the
plane or we'll later look at example of
a signal on the sphere.
Uh, and we have here again the equation
that tells us how the signal transforms.
And we saw that the output of the first
layer group convolution would be a
signal on the group itself.
And again a very similar equation that
tells us how such signals transform.
Uh, in later layers, we will want to
define a group convolution that takes a
signal on G and produces as output also
a signal on G.
Um, and we can give a proof
that is independent of the specifics
of the of the of the space omega and the
group G.
The key insight is that
uh, matching a signal X with a
transformed filter as we do in the group
convolution
is the same as matching the
inverse transformed signal
uh, with the original filter psi. So
that's given by this equation. X
row one G psi equals row one G inverse
times X
uh,
with with psi.
And this is actually something you you
need to show and it depends a little bit
on the properties of the integration
measure
where you need to use it one that has
some invariance property called the Haar
measure. But this is all quite quite
technical. We will not go into it here,
but if you're curious, you can you can
use these words to
to look look it up and also our uh,
uh,
proto book has some some information on
this.
Now using this this key insight, we can
then show in a few lines that indeed the
group convolution is equivariant.
So we have our signal X. We apply a
transformation by H and then we convolve
with psi and we index the output at the
element G.
Now by definition of group convolution,
that's just an inner product between our
input, the transformed X
with a G transformed filter psi.
And using this result, we can take this
H to the other side and now we have that
this is equal to
our
signal X
uh,
inner product with the
filter transformed by H inverse G.
And this is just the group convolution
of psi and X indexed at H inverse G.
And that is nothing else than the
transformed version
the H transformed version of our signal
psi convolved with X.
So that's the proof that group
convolution in the first layer and also
the higher layer version of it uh, is is
equivariant
to the action of the group G.
Now we've shown that group convolution
is equivariant, but we can also reverse
the question. We can say, let's say I
have a signal on a space omega and I
have we know how that transformed
transforms and we have an output signal
space on maybe another space omega or on
group G or whatever. We have a
definition for how that transforms and
now I want to design a linear layer with
some learnable parameters um, that
should be equivariant with respect to
these representations.
And now you can show that if you're
using if the if the group acts on these
spaces in a way that we've just
described by shifting the signal
over the the the plane or shifting it
over the group using the regular
representation then any such linear
equivariant map between these regular
representations is going to be a group
convolution.
And of course there are many technical
details that would have to be mentioned
and if you're interested in this, I
would recommend having a look at the
literature cited here at the at the
bottom.
But that's a that's a pretty cool result
because it tells us that in a way we can
we we don't have to um,
uh, come up with anything new uh,
at least at a fundamental level because
as soon as we we have decided that we we
want our feature spaces to transform
according to a regular representation if
we think that they should be signals on
some space
um, then
uh,
you know, the group convolution is the
most general thing you can do. Now there
are certain downsides in terms of
computation for very large groups
for which
we've developed this steerable CNN
framework that we'll talk in in about in
a minute. Uh, but um,
uh, but still it's nice to know that by
using group convolution, we're not
imposing any kind of
unnecessary constraints on our
linear layers.
Uh, so there's you can then think about,
okay, how do we implement this, right?
So so far we've been talking most mostly
about the mathematics and I I like to
emphasize this because the mathematics
is you know, still going to be the same
in 100 years from now and the
implementation details for how you
actually uh,
compute this is is going to depend on
the hardware and there's going to be
trends and and and different ways of
doing that
that change over the over the years, but
but still it's very important of course
to know about that.
Um, so
how can we implement this group
convolution for the very simple case
again of the discrete rotations and and
translation group P4?
Uh,
so what we'll have is
uh,
we have a set of weights. Those are the
the the the the filters in their upright
position.
And then we have a set of indices that
we can use to to basically create copies
of the of the of the filters in
different orientations. So we create one
copy in the upright orientation, one in
the rotated uh,
or in all four rotations basically. And
that that's the operation we call filter
transformation.
So now we get an expanded uh,
set of filters.
Uh, and those we can just feed into the
conv2D operation that you also use in a
in a standard planar CNN.
Uh,
apply that to the input feature maps and
we get our output feature maps.
And so
that's a very
yeah, here's a here's a visualization of
how that works. Uh, we have our
uh, four
input channels for the filter
corresponding to the different
orientations.
Uh, the filter transformation uses some
indices to create the copies of uh,
filters rotated and cyclically shifted
as you see here in the different rows.
And then this is a filter bank that we
can just apply in conv2D.
So at least for this very simple case
uh, there's very little computational
overhead relative to a standard 2D
convolution. Uh, because the only extra
operation we have to do is this filter
transformation.
Of course if you
uh,
this filter transformation does produce
more filters and so the conv2D operation
will be heavier unless of course you
reduce the number of free free
parameters that you're using
which is often a
good good thing to do so that you you
you get better performance. But you can
also choose to use the same number of
parameters and you have more filters and
you get better
better accuracy at a higher
computational budget.
Now, there are many other approaches
that have been developed. So, first of
all, there's the steerable CNNs that
we'll talk about in a minute. Um this
allows to address some of the
computational issues
that you run into for very large groups.
Uh there's various other ideas like
B-spline CNNs where you define
continuous filters
via B-splines on the on the so-called
tangent space of a Lie group.
Uh LieConv, there's work on scale
equivariance,
and recently what's been quite popular
is equivariant transformers of various
kinds. And I should say that this is
only a tiny sampling of the of the
literature, but there's there's a lot of
work that you can you can find on
equivariant convolutional networks and
other equivariant networks.
So, one other case study that's
interesting to look at is spherical
CNNs. So, this is useful if you have
data that lives on a sphere. So, for
example, in the Earth and climate
sciences, the Earth is a sphere, you
might have some some data
like temperature fields or fields of
wind direction at every point on on the
Earth, and you might want to apply some
kind of analysis, some kind of machine
learning
model to it.
Uh or you might have a omnidirectional
camera on a on a robot.
Uh and that's again a signal on the
sphere.
Uh and when you have a signal on the
sphere, again, according to our our
geometric deep learning
philosophy, you want to think about what
is the symmetry of the sphere. Well,
those are three-dimensional continuous
rotations.
Uh and you want to build layers that are
equivariant to those.
Um now, I'm not going to go into detail
here in the interest of time, but you
can define a convolution on the sphere
that is completely analogous to the to
the case of the plane that we looked at
before. You have a signal on the sphere,
a filter on the sphere, and a
convolution is defined by taking inner
product of your signal on the sphere and
the rotated version of your filter.
Uh and now, just like before, the output
is a function not on the sphere, but on
the group, in this case, the group SO3,
the
rotations in three dimensions, which
whereas the sphere is two-dimensional,
this is a three-dimensional manifold.
So, our output
feature map is a signal on SO3.
And then you can define a group
convolutions for signals on SO3 as well,
using again the the same kind of recipe.
Uh yeah, so this is just saying what I
what I just mentioned, different
domains.
Um
There's ways to implement this using a
Fourier transform,
very complicated, so I won't go into it.
And actually, uh
this was the way we implemented it in
the first our first paper on this topic,
but uh it's it's it's quite complicated,
so I wouldn't necessarily recommend the
spectral approach for this type of
method.
Uh although
Ritz Konder and others have
have found practical ways to to do this.
Uh if if you just want to implement a
group convolution, I I wouldn't
recommend this, but there are spectral
spherical CNNs that work well.
Uh so, yeah, many many approaches to
spherical CNNs. You can
you can use, for example,
graph convolutions,
the spectral spherical CNNs that I
mentioned, and again, this is just a
small sampling of the literature.
There's many many approaches.
Okay, so we've covered a few examples.
We looked at
translation convolution in the in the
last lecture. We've looked at how to
generalize that to include discrete
rotations. We've seen that in
three-dimensional grids, and we've seen
spherical CNNs, and we've seen some
general patterns emerge.
And what I'm going to do now in the in
the the time that we have left is to
just sketch a little bit the general
theory that describes all of these.
Uh where the common theme is that you
have a group of symmetries and acting on
some homogeneous space, we'll say what
that means.
Your signal signal space is a space of
feature sorry, functions on a
homogeneous space.
Um and
the equivariant maps that you're
interested in are generalized kinds of
convolutions.
So, what are homogeneous spaces?
So, we recall from our blueprint, we
have our
domain omega that's always a set
uh with a group action. So, we have a
group element G, and if we
we we apply it to a point in omega, we
get a transformed point in omega. For
this to be a group action, it has to
satisfy certain properties
uh that we covered in previous lectures.
Now, if this action is transitive, then
omega is called a homogeneous space for
G. So, what does that mean?
To be transitive, well, if we have any
two points U and V in our space omega,
then there should exist at least one
group element G such that applying G to
U gives us V.
So, let's look at a few examples of
homogeneous spaces and also
counterexamples.
So, if you have our
domain omega, the plane,
then if we take any two points, let's
say this one
and this one, then
is there a transformation, that is to
say, a translation
that takes one into the other? And the
answer is, of course, yes.
Uh for any point any two points, there's
a translation that maps
uh
one to the other.
We can also consider this same example
for another group, namely the group of
translations and rotations. So, we have
the same space,
and it is also a homogeneous space for
the group of translations and rotations.
Again, because if we have any two
points,
we can find some roto-translation that
maps one into the other. For example,
just a pure translation, and maybe
combined with any rotation around the
the resulting point.
Similarly, for the sphere, if you have
any two points, we can always find a
continuous rotation that maps one to the
other. So, the sphere is a homogeneous
space for the 3D rotation group SO3.
Now, here on the right, you see a
counterexample.
If we have the plane,
uh but we consider as our group of
symmetries only the 2D rotation group,
so rotations around the center
of the of the plane,
uh around the origin,
then uh of course, if you have any two
points that have the same distance to
the origin, we can rotate one into the
other. That's that's indicated here by
these circles, but points at different
distance to the origin, they cannot be
mapped into each other by a rotation.
So, this space splits into these orbits,
these circles.
Um and
whereas in other cases, there's only one
orbit. All the points can be any point
can be mapped anywhere else in the space
by by an appropriate
symmetry transformation.
So, those are homogeneous spaces.
Um now, something very important
structurally about a homogeneous space
is so-called stabilizer subgroup. So, we
have our set omega, and we assume that
this is a homogeneous space for some
group G,
then the stabilizer subgroup of a point
in omega, let's say this point in the
plane,
is the set HU.
That's the set of group elements in G
that leave U invariant. So, if you apply
G to U,
you get back U.
So, let's look at examples. Here we have
the plane, uh and if we take our group G
to be
the translation group R2,
then
it has a trivial stabilizer, because any
translation that we apply, except for
the identity, will move this point away.
Uh and so, only the identity
transformation, that's one element
group, a trivial
group, only that leaves this point
invariant.
However, if you consider the group SE2,
that is, continuous rotations and
translations acting on the plane,
then the stabilizer is the group SO2,
the
group of two-dimensional rotations
around this point.
Uh any translation will move it away,
but any rotations around this point will
leave that point where it is.
So, that's the stabilizer of this point
if you consider this a homogeneous space
for the group SE2.
Uh similarly, the sphere is a
homogeneous space for the rotation group
SO3.
And if we take any point, then we get a
group of rotations around the axis
through that point. Uh that's a group
called SO2.
Uh rotation around axis.
And so, that's the stabilizer of that
group.
Um
now, you can show various things. First
of all, that this is a subgroup. That's
a good exercise. So, you look up again
the definition of a group, and you check
that this set satisfies those, that the
identity is in it, composition is
associative, there's inverses,
uh
Uh and you can show that the stabilizer
of any point U, whichever one you
choose, is going to be the same as an
abstract group. And that's also why
these spaces are called homogeneous.
Every point kind of looks uh the same.
Now, the key
uh thing to to to remember is that a
homogeneous space is completely
characterized by its symmetry group and
the uh the stabilizer subgroup.
And we'll see how that works. All right.
Yeah, well, uh I'll I'll just uh go over
this very quickly, but uh
um just to sketch the the idea.
So,
before we defined a homogeneous space in
a certain way, and then we saw, "Okay,
it has this stabilizer stabilizer
subgroup."
Uh you can also start with a group and
an arbitrary subgroup and construct a
homogeneous space
uh called a a quotient space. There's
some very subtle differences, but I
won't go into that.
So, to understand this, you need to this
concept of a coset. Uh so, a left coset
of a subgroup H in the group G is a set
of this form.
Namely, it's the
combination of our element G
that uh defines the coset together with
every possible element of H from our
subgroup uh capital H.
So, here you see a simple example. Uh
you have the our group of symmetries of
a triangle with flips and rotations, and
we can con- consider the subgroup H
consisting of flips, mirror
transformations, so the identity and the
mirror transformation, or the mirror
combined with rotation, or uh
uh
two you know, uh
uh R squared
um
and uh
you s- what you see already here is the
coset
of the identity here. E * H is just H,
and that's indicated by this green uh
blob.
And then there's two other cosets,
uh
one here and one here. And you can see
that they partition the group. So, every
group element E, M, MR squared, R, etc.,
is in one and exactly one coset.
So, cosets, they kind of carve up your
group into uh equivalence classes called
cosets.
Um and now the set of cosets is called
the quotient. So, if I start with this
group with six elements,
and then I forget about all the group
elements, I just remember which cosets
there are, I get uh well, in this case,
three cosets.
And this space with three points is uh
called the quotient space.
In the case of SO3, you can think of it
as se- some somewhat like, you know,
topologically, it's somewhat like a
sphere with uh a bunch of circles uh
attached. Uh so, a rotation, you can
think of it as a um indicated by an axis
that's a point on the sphere and a
rotation angle around that axis.
And then uh these circles, you can think
of those a little bit like the cosets.
And if you take the quotient, you forget
about the circles, you collapse them to
a point, and as a result, you get the
sphere. So, you can think of the sphere
as a quotient of SO3 by SO2.
Um and yeah, you can show that the group
G acts on this quotient space, and this
is action is transitive, and so indeed G
over H is a homogeneous space, and that
the stabilizer of this action is H, the
group you quotiented by.
So, the high-level picture you can have
in your mind is you have your group, it
gets partitioned into these cosets. If
you quotient them out, uh you get a
quotient space that's a homogeneous
space.
Uh and uh yeah, the group itself can be
thought of as the homoge- homogeneous
space which at each level at each point
a
uh a copy of your subgroup uh or
attached.
All right. So, that's the most important
information if you're studying a
homogeneous space is what is the group
of symmetries and what is the stabilizer
subgroup, and then you basically know
everything you need to know.
So, on this slide, I was going to take
you through an example of how this
applies to the case of sets, which is a
homogeneous space for the permutation
group, but uh
in the interest of time, I'm going to
skip that. It's still an interesting
exercise to to look at. So, have a look
at the handouts later.
Um this also I'm going to skip.
Um
well, this is just to say that you can
understand
uh convolutional spheres uh in this way
as well.
Right. So,
in the last few minutes, I want to
quickly uh
give you the intuition for steerable
CNNs and also the the motivation for it.
So,
uh let me see how to introduce this. So,
um
let's say we have a
uh a signal
um
on our
uh homogeneous space G over H, our
quotient space. So, let's say we're
looking at the roto-translation group
again, and uh uh
our uh our signal lives on the plane.
The that's the roto-translation group
quotiented by the rotation group.
Um and we have a scalar field, let's say
grayscale image.
And now let's say we want to design a uh
convolution layer that gives an output
that's also a scalar uh signal.
Uh and we want it to be equivariant.
Then, you can
uh see that the only way to do that is
to use a circularly symmetric filter.
Because if you use a non-circularly
symmetric filter, if you rotate your
image, you're going to get a different
response. Uh but since you want it to be
a scalar signal, you can only use one uh
one filter, and so uh it should just be
invariant to rotations.
So, that's one option. Then the other
option uh uh
So, so So, okay. So, the problem with
this, of course, is that circularly
symmetric filters are not very
interesting. They don't allow you to
detect very
interesting kinds of patterns.
Then, on the other hand, you can use a
completely free-form filter.
Uh but then, as
we saw in the um
in the ex- example of group
convolutions, you have to apply every
element of your group H to the filter.
And that's fine if there's four
rotations in the plane, or 24, maybe in
3D.
Uh but if your group H is very large,
then this means you get very many
feature channels.
And so, what we're curious about is if
there's anything in between those two,
completely unconstrained filters, but
having a lot of channels,
uh or very constrained filters and
having only one output channel.
Uh there there should be something in
between.
And uh the way to to understand this is
via a
a certain concept called the induced
representation.
So, the regular representation that we
looked at is a special case of this.
And the basic picture is that we have
our homogeneous space with a stabilizer
subgroup H, and we can look at a single
point uh and uh at that point we'll have
a feature vector. In the case of the
discrete rotations and translations, we
had a four we had four orientation
channels at each point, so it's a
four-dimensional vector.
And it has a certain way of
transforming. If you rotate it,
uh we get a cyclic shift.
Um and then the way the whole feature
map, stack of feature maps, transforms
is that each of these columns, each of
these feature vectors, is rotated, and
there's a cyclic shift.
And that's an instance of an induced
representation. So, we have first a
representation of our subgroup H, that's
row, in this case, cyclic shifts, but it
could be something else.
And then from that, you
induce, you build a representation of
your large group G that acts on fields
of those
uh four-dimensional vectors in this
case.
Another extreme example is scalar
fields. Uh the way it rotates is there's
no nothing going on in the channels,
it's just each channel independently is
rotated.
And so, the in this case, the
representation of your rotation group
acting on
uh uh
on a single RGB vector is trivial. It
doesn't do anything. That's another
example of an induced representation.
Uh but there's something in between. So,
here you see an example of a vector
field. You have your RGB image, you can
compute uh you know, convolution with
the spatial derivative filter, and you
get uh
uh you know, an XY vector for each
channel, red, green, and blue.
And you can convince yourself if you
rotate the image and then do the same
operation, the two are
uh related by
uh uh
uh
again, a rotation of each channel and a
rotation among the channel uh vectors
by, you know, 2x2 rotation matrix. And
that's yet another example of a
uh of an induced representation.
Uh it's another example. So, the general
picture is you have a group G, you have
a subgroup H, uh and they together
define a homogeneous space.
You have a representation row of your
subgroup H
uh that that defines how your
geometrical quantity is going to
transform. Is it going to transform
trivially as a scalar?
Do you have a vector field, so
two-dimensional uh representation? Do
you have a field of regular quantities,
where the dimension of your feature
vector is equal to the
uh the size of your subgroup H or
anything else.
Um and then you have your induced
representation that tells you how a
field of such geometric quantities
transforms.
Uh and uh yeah, that's the that's the
idea of an induced representation. And
then you can ask, "Okay, uh maybe I have
an input, let's say a scalar signal as
here, and I want this output another
scalar signal uh or I want a vector
field as output. What kind of
equivariant linear map can I use?"
And the general answer that uh
has been published under different names
like steerable CNNs, harmonic networks,
tensor field networks,
the general answer is that you should do
a convolution uh where the filter is
constrained in some way. Uh so, in the
in the case of scalar to scalar, you
would get the circularly symmetric
filters.
Uh and in other case you get other kinds
of constraints.
Uh and this uh yeah, this uh is
universal again. So,
uh any equivariant linear map uh between
two induced representations, between two
spaces of fields,
uh is on a homogeneous space is going to
be
uh a generalized convolution with such a
constraint kernel.
Uh
and the cool thing here is you can now
classify a lot of different methods that
you can find in the literature by
saying, "What group do they use? What's
the subgroup? Which quotient space does
that give? And what kind of feature
types, what kind of representation uh do
they use?"
So, it's a very very general framework
uh that you can use to understand uh the
whole uh literature on equivariant nets
on homogeneous spaces.
That's it. Uh a little bit over time. Uh
I hope you
uh you got something out of that. Uh and
uh yeah, happy to to take any uh any
questions. Thanks for your attention.
Yes, hello. There are questions in
Campuswire, so I will read them. Ah,
yes, please. Uh I uh
um in full-screen mode, so I can't see
that right now.
So, you're in the
you you you're signing in in Campuswire,
uh or I have to read the question for
you?
No, I yes, sorry. I'll just take a
second. Uh I'm loading the page right
now.
Uh
lectures
lectures channel, right?
Yeah, yeah, yes.
All right, so
let's see what's the first one.
Uh
The the first one is the one of one
method. Is convolution a special case of
group convolution?
Ah, yes, I see. Yeah. Yeah, that that's
exactly right. So,
uh the standard convolution that you
find in
uh well, in in in in in CNNs as the as
you know, first published by Yann LeCun
in the I think the
uh in late '80s or not early '90s,
uh
or before that in the neocognitron if
you want to be really precise about the
history. The the the those uh
kinds of operations are indeed group
convolutions for the special case
where your signal
is a function on uh Z2 on the grid, and
your group
is also Z2. It's the discrete
translation group.
And then uh yeah, you you you you you
know, you turn the crank, you use this
whole general machinery, and out falls
exactly this operation. So, that that
operation of the translational
convolution
is indeed the most general kind of
equivariant linear map
uh for this particular uh
situation.
Um and for other groups and other
homogeneous spaces, you get other kinds
of convolutions, all of them being some
variant of the group convolution or
steerable uh convolution.
Uh all right, in the example with the
rotation, what is omega and C?
And how is the signal defined?
So,
uh
well, I covered different examples of
rotation. So, so one is where you have a
signal on the plane, and you're
considering uh translations and planar
rotations. And the other example is that
you have a signal on the sphere,
uh and you consider
ro- well, rotations of signals on the
sphere.
And so, those correspond to different
omegas.
Uh you can have your omega be the plane,
either discretized or you can
mathematically also talk about a
continuous uh uh plane or continuous
Euclidean space of higher dimension like
three-dimensional.
Uh
or in the case of spherical CNNs, omega
would be a sphere.
Um
and uh as I also explained, in the
higher layers of your convnet, uh after
the after the first layer of group
convolution,
uh you would have the uh omega, the
the domain, be equal to your group. So,
for example, you could have in the
spherical CNNs, first layer is a signal
on the sphere, second layer your signal
is a function on the rotation group.
Um
but
unless that's unless you use
a rotationally symmetric filter, in
which case you can take your output to
also be a signal on the sphere.
Now, C, uh that's the channel dimension,
and as
uh as with any convolutional net, also
in group equivariant and steerable CNNs,
you can just choose an arbitrary
dimensionality for your your channel.
So, in the in the standard convnet, at
each position, you have a number of
feature uh responses for different
filters, and you can freely choose that.
That's just a hyperparameter of your uh
network design that will will determine
how much how many patterns can you
detect, how many filters do you have. Um
and uh also, of course, how many
parameters you're going to to to have to
uh to learn.
All right, so next question. In the case
of convolution uh in the sphere,
can we use UV mapping and continue with
the normal convolution? All right,
that's an excellent question, actually.
And you know, as a as an implementation
trick,
uh I think that would you could do it.
Um I should say, for those who who are
not aware, UV mapping is is basically
referring to uh you know, parameterizing
the sphere. So, if you have a sphere,
you could use, say, latitude and
longitude uh coordinates, and then just
like a map of the world, uh you can you
can plot it in a square or a rectangular
uh piece of the plane. And then, well,
you have a signal on the plane, and now
you can can do uh convolution on that.
The problem with this
uh is that this operation of taking a
sphere and turning it into the plane
doesn't respect the structure of the
sphere,
uh and it doesn't respect the
symmetries. So, first of all, it doesn't
respect the topological structure
because you have to cut open the sphere
in order to lay it flat on a piece of
plane. Um and so, two points that are
very close together on the sphere,
if you cut right between them, then they
will be far away in the plane.
And again, you could maybe do some hacks
to uh uh
to get around that, like you could do a
cyclic convolution, but the sphere has a
very particular topology. So, for
example, at the at the poles, if you
make a cut
uh
like this, then the the point at the
pole will be represented in
the whole
uh top row of pixels. Uh and so, so
things go wrong topologically. That's
first of all. And also,
uh it doesn't respect the the distances
uh because there's no way to uh turn a
sphere into a plane without stretching
or or or screwing the uh the plane. Or
at least, you're always going to lose
some important geometrical
uh information. And so, what what what
does that
uh mean? Well, if I if I uh learn a um
uh if if I do this planarization, and
then I learn a square filter,
as I'm
shifting this filter translationally
over the plane to do my convolution,
that is going to actually correspond to
a very weird kind of distortion of that
filter on the sphere. So, what you
really want is you want one filter on
the sphere, and you want to just rotate
it over the sphere uh during your
convolution,
uh where yeah, you really have the same
pattern that you're detecting at
different um
uh
positions and orientations.
Uh but if you do it via this
two-dimensional
uh approach, uh implementation strategy,
effectively, you're going to be
stretching your your filter. And so,
that's undesirable, and that's why you
you would use the uh yeah, spherical CNN
framework.
And then uh question about B-spline
CNNs.
So, basically, uh so this applies to Lie
groups. Uh so, Lie groups are
groups that are smooth. So, they're the
it's a group that is also a smooth
manifold where the group operations are
are smooth.
Uh so,
uh
the simple examples include uh
continuous translations and rotations
scaling and such things.
Um, so
you can do it essentially calculus
differentiation on your group.
Um, so that's where it applies and then
because you so in a Lie group
there's something called the Lie algebra
which is basically you can think of that
as the tangent plane to your
Lie group. So your Lie group is a
manifold you can think of it as a curved
space. The simplest case two-dimensional
rotation is just a circle. In the case
of SO3 I tried to visualize it as a
sphere with some circles on top. So a
little bit misleading but you know, you
can think of it as some curved space.
Um,
and any manifold any smooth
manifold has a tangent space at every
point. So in the case of the circle you
can take a point and then you can draw
the line tangent to the circle. That's
the tangent space. In a higher
dimensional manifold you'll get a higher
dimensional tangent space. And now
there's a very nice way that you can
parameterize the elements of your group
by the elements of the tangent space at
the identity.
Um,
and that's what the beast line CNN does.
It defines a filter on this tangent
space which is a flat linear space.
Um,
uh, using something called a spline and
then it maps that to the group
or the or the homogeneous space.
And it does a convolution that way. For
for details how to do that you know,
computationally how to implement that I
would recommend
looking at the paper.
So that's it. That's the last question
in campus wire. If anyone has other
questions
also happy to answer those.
If not I have to go because actually in
15 minutes I have to give another talk.
So I would like to take another look at
the slides.
Um,
so if it's okay with you I will stop
sharing and
yeah, I'll see you soon at the next
lecture and I'll also be on campus wire
to check if there's any further
questions about this lecture.